alien isolation sometimes hints at being
the alien game you've always wanted one
that makes the alien terrifying one that
prioritizes staying safe over aggressive
action this game occasionally captures
both that gut-wrenching sense of fear
and the momentary comfort of escape
every breath could be your last
and so you savor each one oh but how I
wish these moments were more common in
alien isolation most of the game is
devoted to door opening lever pulling
and walking so very much walking and
backtracking so many old and predictable
video game cliches my facility online oh
that's just great what makes alien
isolation so ultimately disappointing is
that when it's on it's on you our Ellen
Ripley's daughter Amanda
seeking information about your mother's
fate aboard the Sebastopol a derelict
Space Station home to a remaining
population of skittish survivors and a
snarling xenomorph drone the game is at
its best when the alien is a clear and
present danger you crouched slink and
peek around corners and above crates
from a first-person perspective avoiding
the glances of that gross and
frightening creature
when all mechanics are working as
intended
alien evasion is dread distilled into
its purest simplest form you are armed
with a couple of standard firearms and a
few helpful gadgets but the motion
tracker is the most vital tool and
possess hold a button and the trackers
dot shows you the relative location of
nearby entities friends and foes alight
the tracker does not tell you however if
the alien is above you or below you
hearing the xenos clawed feet can
paralyze you with fear and you must
battle your basic fighter flight
instincts when you hear the aliens
shuttering exoskeleton run away if it
sees you and you'll probably die the
thing is fast try to fight it at least
before you grab a flamethrower that
temporarily sentence scurrying and you
will definitely die
your best bet is to stay crouched stay
hidden and stay aware these are the
moments when alien isolation weighs
heaviest on your soul hide in a locker
and you see the alien enter the room its
idols up to your hiding place and you
hold your breath if the Z no here's your
gasps or if you fail to lean into the
rear of the locker it snatches you from
your shelter and you peer into its two
gaping maws before succumbing to death
so I can't deny the appeal of dodging
the murderous Menace but these game
defining high points account for only a
few chapters out of many an alien
isolation doesn't even make the most out
of them the game frequently changes the
rules such as allowing the alien to camp
out for you and overhead openings
without telling you the trial and error
combined with the infrequent chances to
save can be frustrating we're still
alien encounters are limited to just
those few levels typically you're
walking pulling levers riding elevators
and of course walking some more this is
the down time the time for building
atmosphere in alien isolation at least
embraces the right 1970s retro
futuristic style the game itself however
is not much of a looker even though the
alien itself looks fantastic that's
access and server hot reception
the exploration ultimately falls flat a
victim to backtracking and simplistic
gameplay elements devoid of creativity
many video games features security
cameras that alert the enemy to your
presence but an alien isolation the
camera off switch is often located
directly beneath the camera sometimes
you must log into computer terminals to
find codes that unlock important doors
but the email with the code might be on
the same terminal that does the
unlocking three wiring stations that
allow you to disable cameras may also
allow you to manipulate the sevastopol
air purification mechanism but rarely
does this have a meaningful effect
Android serve as your most frequent foe
in alien isolation and they're common
enough that it's tempting to bash them
straight on with a stun baton a typical
synthetic turncoat won't take too kindly
to a direct attack though and will
aggressively fling you at a nearby wall
if not outright choke you the
first-person perspective makes becoming
a synthetics personal yo-yo frightening
and disorienting you feel Ripley's fear
as you desperately scan the environment
seeking a clear path through danger
other synthetic encounters are simply
ridiculous though to deal with
synthetics is often to engage in a silly
game of tag in which you lead a few
androids around in circles until you buy
yourself enough time to turn and toss a
Molotov cocktail at them it's an
encounter with synthetics at the bottom
of a late game elevator that sends alien
isolation zooming off the rails the game
tries to mimic an action game poorly
before reaching its unsatisfying
conclusion more than a dozen long often
boring hours after you started alien
isolation provides us a glimpse at the
ultimate alien game it's too bad that
brief glimpse is surrounded by so many
hours of uneven
Oh filler